[Music]
we love the holiday season here at the
things however with the holidays comes
responsibility the responsibility of
buying presents that is sometimes it can
be hard to get everyone you want a
present and keep within your budget
hopefully though this video will give
you some ideas stay tuned
for what to get for the person in your
life who mainly communicates via text
and the internet if you haven't visited
the things before then we'd really
appreciate if you could give this video
a like and hit the subscribe button
today we are going to show you 10
amazing toys you can buy on Amazon for
under $5 fisher-price musical smartphone
children from across the years have
grown up playing with fisher-price toys
they are popular with small kids and
with their parents too you know that
you're going to get something that will
entertain babies and toddlers and charm
the grown-ups too did you know that the
company was founded back in 1930 all
four founders had a strong background in
the toy industry with Herman price
making games for a company and Helen
Schell running a toy shop in the city of
being Hampton the company which started
off by making toy ducks out of wood like
values that centered on intrinsic play
value ingenuity strong construction good
value for the money and action each
principles are things that remain a key
part of their products today we had a
look on Amazon and we were pleased to
see that there was a fisher-price toy in
our price bracket the musical smartphone
is kind of like a modern-day update of
the classic toy telephone that we played
with when we were tiny this is bright
cheerful cute and clever one of the
things we like is that it even has its
own selfie feature that's right this is
a toy phone with a mirror hey guys we
are so excited to announce we're
producing our own
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section lefty here
from you see you there
munch can wind up swimming penguin bath
toy some kids love bath time however
just as mini hate it so if you're a
parent and you want to make having a
bath and being hygienic fun for your
little one then you have to break out
the bath toys there's a pretty cool
variety of them from the traditional
rubber ducks and beyond but what caught
our eye is this toy penguin we have a
soft spot for penguins here at the
things so this is definitely our cup of
tea just take a look at it it's kind of
small less than five and a half inches
but it certainly packs a heck of a lot
of fun into it also it wears goggles
that's a plus point for any toy in our
humble opinions and it looks kind of
cute and fun as well so it'll be
something that will be useful popular
and generally good for your child and
the way that it works on a wind-up basis
is another major plus point your child
and you for that matter will be
absolutely intrigued by this it
certainly looks like it will be a lot of
fun to play with the company that makes
it munchkin has a good reputation too so
you know you'll be getting value for
money with all those things in mind
we've definitely say this is a bargain
lego creator red racer three one oh five
five building kit if there's one toy
that gets praise from just about
everyone up just about every age then
it's Lego these little Danish plastic
bricks are ubiquitous you can find them
in homes across the world one of the
cool things about Lego is that it can
pretty much be anything you want it to
be you can follow the instructions that
are in the box and build something
pretty cool or you can just let your
imagination run riot and be limited only
by what you can dream up well that and
how many bricks you have with you Lego
is such a phenomenon it even inspired
it's very own film the lego movie hits
cinemas in 2014 and it was a massive hit
with audiences young and old alive but
do you know where the word lego comes
from well as you may well know already
Lego was founded in Denmark in 1932 by
ole Kirk Christiansen and its name is an
abbreviation for the Danish phrase leg
dot which means play well it's a pretty
good name because people do play well
with Lego and you can play cheaply too
this red racer car kit will set you back
just
99 that's great value for money although
we still can't decide if we were to get
it whether we'd end up using it to build
the car or something else
Patt charmer won the teaser toy in this
video today we've mainly been talking
about toys for children that you can get
on Amazon for less than five dollars
however it's not just kids that like
playing with toys and being entertained
we know that if you've got a cat you'll
know just how much your cat likes to
play this is the sort of toy that you
dangle down and wave around and your cat
chases it it sounds pretty simple but we
reckon your pet will absolutely love it
what's great about cat toys is that you
can get them pretty cheaply for instance
it won't cost that much to get them a
toy mouse but they can bat around or
even a small pouch of catnip that they
can have fun with that possibilities are
pretty much limitless when it comes to
cat toys if you were to adopt a kitten
though he warns you could end up in it
for the long term did you know that the
world's oldest cat lived to be
thirty-eight years old
creampuff was a domestic Shorthair cat
he was born in 1967 and passed away in
2005 that means that she lived to be the
equivalent of 165 in human years
that's pretty amazing she lived in
Austin Texas USA with her owner
Jake Perry Jake must have been doing
something right because another cat of
his grandpa lived to be thirty four
Crayola Crayons
kids love to let their imaginations run
riot but one of the best ways to harness
that creative energy is to encourage
them to draw it's a useful skill to have
and it can lead to a passion that can
definitely last your child a lifetime
and one of the best ways to encourage
them to draw is by buying them a box of
crayons they may not look like much but
that's where you would be wrong kids who
have crayons can do some cool smart
clever and funny things and these are no
ordinary crayons either
these are Crayola crayons these are the
things that millions of children across
the world have used they're the ones you
almost certainly would have used when
you were in kindergarten or elementary
school however Crayola hasn't always
been called Crayola it was originally
called Binney & Smith after its founders
Edwin Binney and see Harold Smith they
were two cousins from New York City who
founded the firm as an industrial
colorants business in 1890 however 13
years later they started making wax
crayons and that's where the name
Crayola comes from it was dreamed up by
Edwin Vinnie's wife alice stead Binney
if you wonder why the name was chosen it
was a combination of Cray French for
chalk and Ola coming from the word oily
dss why fidget spinner one of the
biggest toy crazes in the middle years
of the 2010s is the fidgets spinner
these things came out of nowhere to be
absolutely everywhere pretty much
overnight if you don't know what a
fidget spinner is there a small toy
usually with three spokes it's kind of
shaped a little bit like the star in the
mercedes-benz logo if you know that they
have a ball bearing in the middle that's
where you hold it and flip it around so
it spins it doesn't take much effort to
do they were originally designed as a
stress feeding device the idea was that
you'd spin your spinner around and it
would provide a distraction from
whatever it was that was bothering you
they were even marketed as being useful
for people with conditions such as
autism and ADHD although there haven't
yet been any specific studies that back
those claims up anyway they're pretty
addictive things so it wasn't really any
great surprise that they crossed over
and became a massive craze if you want
to get either yourself or someone you
know a fidget spinner you can pick one
up on Amazon for less than five bucks
this one's pretty cool it shaped like a
wheel and it's brightly colored too so
it stays shiny when it gets sunny and
one spin keeps it going for three
minutes - mystery minecraft toy people
of all ages who enjoy video games will
know just how big a deal
minecraft is if you don't enjoy video
games well we'll try to describe it to
you basically the game which is
available on two kinds of Xbox two types
of PlayStation 3 mobile phone platforms
and home computers is kind of like Lego
you know how they say that the only
thing that limits you with Lego is your
imagination well the same applies to
Minecraft too you can use different
screen building blocks to create your
very own world you populate it with your
character or characters and you take it
from there
there are lots of different ways to play
the game - there's a survival mode where
you have to get resources to build the
world and maintain health there's a
creative mode where you get unlimited
resources to build with and you can fly
there's an adventure mode where you can
play on laps created by other people and
there's a spectator mode where players
can move throughout the game without
being affected by gravity or collisions
if you know a Minecraft fan you can get
them a toy of one of the games many
characters there's only one issue you
might have though it's a mystery as to
which one it is that's because this is a
blind box so you'll be as intrigued by
their presence as they will fall Patrol
plush chase dog
one of the biggest children's TV success
stories of the 2010s is paw Patrol
this show is about brave young dogs who
often save the day in Adventure Bay has
become a worldwide smash hit it's been
picked up and syndicated to more than
100 countries and has been translated
into nearly as many languages the
program has inspired stage shows books
and toys since it was first shown on
Canada's t-bo kids back in 2013 so
there's a very good chance that the
child in your life is a fan one of our
favorite members of the paw patrol is
chase the German Shepherd police pup
maybe he's your child's favorite of the
pups too he's very cute and he's also
very brave he is the sort of dog who
will look out for you when your backs
against the wall pretty typical of the
German Shepherd it's bravery loyalty
strength and intelligence make it a
natural choice for police and guard work
and if your child has chase as their
favorite pop then you can get them an
ideal toy without having to break the
bank this lovely soft plush toy Chase
will set you back just five bucks so you
can make your kids day without having to
spend too much money so that can only be
a good thing we think minions balls
perhaps one of the most unlikely success
stories to have come out of the world of
cinema and the 21st century is the
Despicable Me
franchise just think about it for a
moment the studio behind it illumination
entertainment had never even made a
movie before the 2010 film hit cinemas
but the tales of GRU his adopted
daughters Margo Edith and
Magnus not to mention the minions who
have worms their way into the hearts of
moviegoers across the globe we are big
fans of all the characters but if we had
to say which was our favorite we'd
probably narrow it down to three can you
guess who were thinking of that's right
it's Bob Stuart and Kevin also known as
the minions even if you don't know the
Despicable Me Films you still recognize
these guys
they are the odd-looking yellow
creatures who wear blue overalls and
help out the series main character grew
with his nefarious schemes these guys
are basically the mascots of the
franchise and you can see them
everywhere they got so successful that
they ended up starring in their own
movie called imaginatively enough
minions and for the minions fan in your
life you can get some pretty
cool-looking bouncy balls with their
faces on it for just $5 we think that's
pretty cool so if you or your loved ones
love both balls and minions this is
ideal rainbow poop emoji cushion it's an
unspoken secret amongst parents across
the world that quite often kids like
some pretty gross seeming things you
don't believe us
well have you read any fairy stories
lately lots of horrible things going on
there or are you familiar with the works
of Roald Dahl the chances are you saw
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
and that wasn't short of some pretty
horrible although in a funny kind of way
stuff so please believe us when we tell
you that this Christmas there are far
worse stocking fillers to give them this
rainbow-colored poop emoji cushion yes
we know but what's so cool about it is
that because it's colored like a rainbow
you can pretend that it's not poop in
fact maybe it isn't a poop after all
perhaps it's an ice cream that's
possible we suppose the word emoji comes
from the Japanese e meaning picture and
emoji meaning character the word ended
up superseding the English emoticon
round about the time they became more
and more ubiquitous
in fact they were so successful that
there was a film based on them it was
called the emoji movie and it came out
in the summer of 2017 but we're
wondering what's your favorite emoji and
what is the emoji you wish someone would
create let us know in the comments
that's all for 10 amazing toys you can
buy on Amazon for under $5 if you liked
it you should check out five cartoon
reboots that are way better than the
original then
watching and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]